if the temperature outside changes by
half a degree you won't even feel it
such a small change is almost
imperceptible to human senses but half a
degree of global temperature change
could be little short at the end of the
world we recognize or at least the world
humanity is inhabited for the last few
millennia in 2015
governments agreed a deal in Paris to
stop global warming rising past two
degrees and to try to keep it below 1.5
degrees so what's in part a degree at
1.5 degrees there would still be some
precious rainforests polar bears and
coral reefs on planet earth albeit
seriously diminished sea levels would
rise but relatively slowly so major
cities like London Jakarta and Mumbai
have a better chance of continuing life
as normal droughts and flooding would be
at a level where food production can
keep up with population growth millions
of extra climate refugees could stay at
home and others could avoid starvation
getting to this world isn't impossible
it means cutting greenhouse gas
emissions by half within a decade and
then being carbon neutral by mid-century
so we'd be closing coal power stations
instead of building new ones and every
car would be electric
would be restoring forests instead of
cutting them down and even aircraft
would be carbon neutral it's not
impossible but it is unlikely the fossil
fuels Lobby is powerful some heads of
state even deny the reality of climate
change transforming the global energy
system will take time and trillions of
dollars of investment but it's also an
opportunity so if we're too slow and
instead of 1.5 we get the extra half
degree what then according to the latest
IPCC report in a world 2 degrees warmer
you go diving in the tropical seas but
the flourishing coral reefs are gone
instead you would like to see a
graveyard of rubble and algae back on
land heat waves are becoming
increasingly deadly with approximately
65 million extra people exposed to
exceptional heat waves each year imagine
yourself at the North Pole but all you
see is open winter the polar bears have
gone along with the sea ice that used to
be their home you take a boat to the
edge of Greenland but that frozen
wasteland is taller huge will melt water
rivers Thunder into the ocean where they
add to the rising sea levels that are
beginning to flood the world's
coastlines take a trip to Miami Mumbai
or Melbourne and you'll probably need a
boat
faced with the rising seas 10 million
people could be forced to pack up and
move
global harvests would also suffer and in
developing countries especially the
number of people experiencing water
scarcity doubles this would be a world
of increasing poverty and human misery
all for what for half a degree and for a
few more years of cold smokestacks and
oil industry profits the choice is ours
but not for long every bit of warming
every year every choice matters but like
a desert Mirage the one point five
degree world is receding into the
distance with every year we delay if
carbon emissions keep growing for
decades to come
then even two degrees looks hopeful
that's a world a darker world of flood
fire and conflict that we can barely
even imagine
we can still choose
that half a degree window between
unsettling dream and full-blown
nightmare but it's closing fast thanks
for watching don't forget to subscribe
and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos
see you again soon